همم كما اود ان ارحب ايضا في هذا المكان
بانضمام جمهوريه توغو للتحالف ليصبح ضد
الدول الاعضاء في 86 دوله ومنظمه
وباعتباره اكبر تحالف دولي لمواجهه هذا
التنظيم الارهابي
خلال الاجتماعاتنا اليوم ناقشنا سبل اعاده
استقرار في الاراضي المحرره من تنظيم داعش
في سوريا والعراق باعتبارها من ضمن قائمات
لدى التحالف واكدنا على اهميه استمرار
الجهود في هذا الاطار كما اكد المشاركون
على الالتزامهم واستمرارهم في الحد من
مصادر التمويل الارهاب والوسائل نشره
والترويج كما تجد الاشاره هنا اذا ترى
المملكه لمجموعه مكافحه التمويل داعش
وجهودها الكبيره في اطار تنسيق عمل كافه
الدول في التحالف للتصدي لتمويل هذا
التنظيم كما بحثنا الاجراءات التي يمكن
اتباعها لمجابهه الارهاب والمنشيات
المسلحه في غرب افريقيا ودول الساحل ووسط
وجنوب افريقيا والتي بدورها تزعزع الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه وان المملكه ستشارك
في رئاسه مجموعه خاصه بافريقيا ايمانا من
التحالف
باهميه التركيز على هذا التحدي نظرا لما
يشكله
يعني مصدر للتحديد ليس فقط لدول الساحل
لكن لدول المنطقه اجمع والعالم وهنا اود
ان اسمي على هذا التركيز المستجد على
التحدي التي تواجه القاره الافريقيه من
الارهاب واستشعارنا جميعا في المجتمع
الدولي بمسؤولياتنا تجاه التعاون والتنسيق
لوجهابه هذا التحدي كما اود ان اؤكد على
اهميه مجاواجهه التنظيمات الارهابيه في
افغانستان لضمان ان لا تصبح مجددا امنا
لاعاده التنظيمات
وكذلك مهم ان نؤكد مره اخرى على ضروره
التزام المجتمع الدولي والطلاعي بادواره
في مواجهه التحديات المشتركه ومن ابرز
الارهاب والعمل على توفير البيئه الملائمه
بعوده النازحين في سوريا والعراق واجراء
الاصحاحات القضائيه لمحاسبه الارهابيين
واهميه اطلاع الدول الغنيه بمسؤوليتها
اتجاه عوده مواطنيها من مناطق النزاع
وحمايه الاجيال القادمه من اضرار هذه
الافه
وتبعاتها والحقيقه من المؤسف ان لازال
هناك عدد من الدول الغنيه الدول المتقدمه
التي ترفض استعاده مواطنيها
وترمي بهذا العبء على دول المتاثره الاكثر
تاثرا بالارهاب المملكه تقوم بدورها
وتستعد كافه مواطنيها من مواقع الصراع
ونحن مستعدون ان نساعد من يحتاج فيما
يتعلق باعاده التاهيل والانخراط المجتمع
لكن الدول كافه عليها مسؤوليه تحمل
ما قام به مواطنوها وان يستعيدونهم
ويرفعون هذا العب عن الدول المتاثره كما
او في هذا المناسبه نؤكد على متانه
العلاقه السعوديه الامريكيه التاريخيه
وما ناقشته مع صديقي توني البارحه في
لقائنا ثنائي وكما ايضا تم مناقشته في
لقاء سيدي العهد
في التشاور في القضايا ذات الاهتمام الشرك
الى تعزيز الامن والاستقرار الدولي
واستعرضنا ملفات كثيره في المنطقه كذلك
اطر التعاون بين بلدينا وهناك مجال واسع
لهذا التعاون وسنستمر في بحث سبل
دعم هذا التعاون لما في مصلحه بلدينا
اود ختاما اود ان نشير ان هذه نقطه مهمه
الحقيقه ان المشاركون اكدوا على ان التطرف
والارهاب في كافه اشكاله ومظاهرها يجب ان
لا يرتبط باي دين او جنسيه او مجموعه
عرقيه ولا يكون عذرا
لاتخاذ اي اجراءات او اي تفرقه او اي
عنصريه تجاه اي مجموعه عرقيه
وان لا يكون المسلمون عرضه لمضايقات مجرد
لان بعض الفئات ربما
انتهجت نهجا مخالفا وهذا ينطبق على جميع
العرقيات شكرا واعطي الكلمه للسيد توني
بنك
وزير الخارجيه فيصل اشكركم اشكركم على
ضيافتكم
وعلى جمع الشركائنا الاقليمين والدوريين
هنا في الرياض عندما سافر رئيس الى جده في
الصيف الماضي اكد على اهميه الشرق الاوسط
من اجل مصالح امريكا على المدى البعيد
ونحن ملتزمون بالاستمرار وتعزيز شركاتنا
في المنطقه معا نستطيع ان نحقق التقدم
لكافه شعوبنا ليس فقط لمعالجه التحديات
والزمات الحاليه
لصياغه رؤيا حاسمه لمستقبلنا المشترك عبر
لاعمقيه لقد حققنا هذا التقدم عبر عده
جبهات من خلال العامه وشركائنا السعوديين
وبجلس التعاون الخليجي والعمل اليوم مع
التحالف الدولي
لهزيمه داعشاب خارجيه لقد انهيت اجتماعا
مع هذا التحالف الدولي الولايات المتحده
ممتنه لقياده المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ليس فقط في استضافتي هذا الاجتماع بل
لاسهاماتها المستمره
في كل يوم تحقيق هذه المهمه مع تحالفنا
يستعيد الاراضي اذا كانت يسيطر عليها 11
وتكبدهم خساره فادحه في قيادتها فتبقى
داعش تمثل تهديد المستمر لاجتماع الوزاري
ركز على عده مجالات ضروريه
من ضمنها تحقيق الاستقرار في المناطق
المحرره من داعش لكي لا تستغل الجماعه
الامن الضعيف او الظروف الانسانيه
والاقتصاديه
التي تترك السكان كما اعتقد ياسين وكما
سمعتم من وزير الخارجيه
اعاده
الارهابيين الجانبي الى اوطانهم
نحن نعمل ايضا مع التهديدات الناشئه من
ضمنها جهود اذا عاشت في شبه الصحارة
الافريقيه وداعش خرسان اعضاء الاتحاد 86
مركزين بشكل اكبر لاكمالي هذه المهمه
للتخلص من داعش المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
عندما تولى رئيس الاداره كانت الحرب
مستعره وكانت تواجه اوضع اسوا اوضاع
انسانيه في العالم والان نعمل بشكل مكثف
مع السعوديه وشركائه اخرين
تحقيق هذا
الاستقرار في القتال الذي مدام على 14
شهرا اليوم في سنه الفرصه ايضا للقاء رئيس
اليمن
لمناقشه المسار المستقبلي هدفنا واهدافنا
وعمليه يمنيه شامله بواسطه الامم المتحده
والطالب العداله والمساءله
وبالختام تقود الى حل سياسي
بالخلافات في اليمن المفضل سوف يستمر
بالعمل مع الاطراف والشر كان في المنطقه
في الايام السابع المقبل لحل المشاكل
العالقه في وجه السلام الدائم الولايات
المتحده والسعوديه لجميع الخليجي تركز
وايضا على نشاطات ايران مزعزع المنطقه من
ضمنها دعمها على الارهابي
والمليشياتها على السفن البحريه والتصعيد
النووي هناك متحده
بايمانها بين دبلوماسيه الاجانب الضغوط
الاقتصاديه ورد او التعاون الدفاع يه
القوي هي السبيل الامثل لمعالجه ومواجهه
هذه النشاطات الخطره نحن ندعم جهود
السعوديه
حول ازمه السودان امريكا
والسعوديه تقود حملات الدبلوماسيه لدفع
جانبين للالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار
وللسماحين بوصول لمساعدات الانسانيه الى
الشعب السوداني سوف نستمر بالعمل تجاه
التحقيق وقد اطلق نار دائم
وتشكيله قياده مدنيه انتقالي
اثيوبيا لمراجعه التطبيق الحالي
واتفاق الثاني
انهى المروعه في
اوه على اطراف تدركوا الاعمال
الى جانب التسويه او امريكا تستمر وتشاركه
السعوديه او الخليج علاقاتنا تمتد بعيدا
عن مجرد هذه التحديات فهي ضروريه جدا
لتوسيعيه
التقدم لشعبنا ولشعوب العالم
وعبر الشركات البنات تحتيه العالميه
والاستثمارات امريكا والسعوديه تعملان
ومعاني تقديمي البلد التحتيه ذات الجوده
العاليه
لمصلحه
المتوسط وحتى بتيجات رقميه من خلال
التكنولوجيا الاتصالات
مثل الشبكات السحابيه الامنه وقليله
التكلفه نحن كافح ازمه المناخ ونسرع
الانتقال الى طاقه نظيف في المنطقه عبر
الشركات الثنائيه اللي الذي اتفق ذو
القناه في الصيف الماضي والذي يفك عنه
طاقه الهيدروجين النظيف والطاقه الشمسيه
وغيرها جانب اساسي من استراتيجياتنا
لتحقيق المنطقه المستقره او حواء تخفيقي
الى توترات الخليجي مترابطه عن اكثر من اي
وقت سبق كمنطقه وكذلك مع دول اخرى في
الشرق الاوسط من ضمنها اسرائيل امريكا
ستستمر بلعب بدور اساسي في تعزيز وتوسيع
عمليه التطبيع كما قال الرئيس بايدن في
جده الحقوق العالميه والحريات والحمايه
التي توفرها هي اولويه اساسيه لامريكا
وشراكه سعوديه الامريكيه تتعمق خلال
تطور عمله حقوق الانسان لهذا اتخذنا خطوات
تاريخيه لتعزيز دور المراه في مكان العمل
والتسامح بين الزيادات المعتقدات ضمن
اجنده هذه الدوله الطموحه
وهذه نقطه اوضحتها بشكل جيد في اجتماعاتنا
هذا الاسبوع في الاسبوع الماضي امريكا
رواد الفضاء الامريكيين عادوا لارض بعد
قضاء عشره ايام معا في محطه الفضاء
الدوليه وتلك المهمه شملت ريحانه
عربيه تزور الفضاء وفي رساله الاولى من
الفضاء ريحانه توقعت بان المستقبل مشرق
ولذلك اقول لنجعله مشرقا معا شكرا
والان مع صله الزملاء من وسائل الاعلام
قناه العربيه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان
هل التهديدات اليوم التي يشكلها تنظيم
داعش في بعض دول افريقيا وما دفع الاعلان
بانضمام السعوديه لرئاسه مجموعه التركيز
المعنيه بالشام الافريقي لمواجهه التنظيم
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
اجتماعات مع ولي عهد السعوديه الامير محمد
بن سلمان لساعات وايضا اوضحت او كما وصفت
انه اجتمعت معه لساعات وناقشت معهم ملفات
او ملفات كثيره هل لنا ان نعرف بالتفصيل
عن هذه الملفات وايضا الملفات التي يرغ
بها ولي العهد السعودي مع امريكا شكرا لك
شكرا هاني
منظمه المملكه لرئاسه المجموعه الخاصه
بافريقيا ايمانا من
بمسؤولياتنا تجاه الشراكه العميقه التي
تملك المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع القاره
الافريقيه الق ننظر لها
كمصدر مهم
للتعاون والتنسيق والدول الافريقيه كلها
بالمجمل لها علاقه قويه بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه ونحن مساهمون اساسيون في التنميه
في تلك الدول
ونستشعر بمسؤولياتنا تجاه الحفاظ على ما
حصل من تقدم في هذه الدول والتعاون معها
والتنسيق فيما يخص مجابهه هذا التعديد
الذي يهدد امنه واستقرار القاره كافه
وينعكس حقيقه ايضا على امن واستقرار
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بحكم الجوار
والمسؤوليه مشتركه لمواجهه هذا التحدي
بالذات ان كثير من الدول الافريقيه ينقصها
القدرات التقنيه والمعرفه في هذا المجال
وكما واجهنا داعش في العراق وسوريا كمجتمع
دولي المسؤوليه ايضا ان نواجه التنظيمات
الارهابيه في القاره الافريقيه كمجتمع
دولي وبالتنسيق والتعاون
وسنعمل على ذلك وسندعم كل جهود الدوليه في
هذا الاطار
ما ذكره مع الوزير الخارجيه ومره اخرى
وكتذكر فان هذا التحالف
الدوله منظمه وهو اكبر تحالف في العالم
وقد حقق تقدم نجاحا كبيرا جدا مدعم واربعه
عشر في استعاده الاراضي التي سيطر عليها
داعش في العراق وسوريا
والتخلص من القيادات العليا
وتقليلي التهديد ولكن التهديد مستمر
والى جانب ذلك فهو
ينتقل الى مناطق اخرى وبشكل من افريقيا
وهذا كان علينا ان نركز اليوم وفي تحالفنا
على بعض التحديات التي يواجهها الشركائنا
في افريقيا وبشكل خاصتي الساحل وغرب
افريقيا
فالامر بتكره التعالف هو انه يتكيف ومرن
وحتى مع استمرار تركيزنا العراقي وسوريا
لضمان
عدم اعاده بروز تهديد 11
يجب ان نضمن تركيزنا على مناطق اخرى قد
يكون فيه اكثر شاطا وكما ذكرنا الان احد
مناطق افريقيا ولهذا السبب تركيزها هذا
التحالف منصب على افريقيا بالشراكه
الكامله مع الدول الافريقيه
اخر شيء ودون اذكره وما هو جدير بالذكر من
نقاشاتنا اليوم وكل العام الذي قمنا به هو
ضروره المقاربه المكثفه الامن
الضروري ولكن هناك تحديات كيف نواجهها من
داعش وسمعنا من شركائنا فنظرات التعامل مع
المخاوفه واحتياجاتي المجتمعات المهمشه
وتوفير الفرص الاقتصاديه وضمان
وجود الحوكمه الجيده
والمقاربه السياسيه شفافه كل هذه الاشياء
الضروره ضد داعش ومنعها امن التجنيد
والتوسعه في مناطق اخرى
السؤال الثاني
شكرا
معالي وزير الخارجيه صاحب السموم
السعوديه للحصول على الدعم لتطوير
برنامجها النووي المدني بمقابله تطبيق
علاقاتها مع اسرائيل وهل تقولون بان هذا
الشرط غير قابل للتفاوض من اجل التطبيق
والسؤال اخر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
قامت بالعديد من الاصلاحات ان جماعتها
حقوق الانسان افادت عن عمليات اقامه وهي
استجابتكم ذلك الضغط التي تواجهونه من
نظراتكم الامريكيين حول هذه المساله
الوزير بلانكن ناقشت مع ولي العهد السعودي
مثل التطبيع ما هو التقدم الذي حصل ومدى
امكانيه الوصول الى هذا الاتفاق انه ربما
يسرب بعيده عملت تسريع التسلح مع ايران
وحلب
اي ضمانات من ولي العهد اتجاه اطلاق
المساجين السياسيين
شكرا جزيلا كما يخص التعاون النووي ليس
سرا نحن نطور برنامجنا نووي المدني
ونفضل ان
تكون امريكا متقدمه لتطوير هذا البرنامج
الدول الاخرى تتقدم هذا البرنامج مع افضل
تكنولوجيا في العالم وهذا سيتطلب
اتفاق معين لدينا خلافات فرعي ونحن نعمل
على جاد اليه للعمل معا على تكنولوجيا
المدنيه وان اسعى قدمت في هذا البرنامج
اما التطبيع وكما قلتم مسبقا وواضح نحن
نؤمن بان التطبيع يصب في مصلحه المنطقه
وسوف يقدم فؤاد كبيره للجميع ولكن من دون
ايجاد السبيله للسلام لشعب الفلسطيني بدون
معالجه هذا التحدي فان اي تطبيع
يكون له فوائد محدوده وبالتالي علينا
الاستمرار بالتركيز على ايجاد السبيل
تجاهها حلت دولتين
والمساره تجاه منحى الفلسطينيين الكرامه
والعداله
وامريكا لديها وجهه نظر مشابهه من المهمين
جدا ان نستمر على هذه الجهود سالتي عن
حقوق الانسان والاصلاحات
ومن المعروف اننا قمنا او حققنا تقدمه
كبيره في الاصلاحات المملكه وما نقوم هنا
كله وفقا لتقييمنا فيما يصب في مصلحه
بلادنا وهم مدفوع باحتياجات ورغبات الشعب
السعودي انتم عشتم بعض الايام هنا واتمنى
ان تكونوا قد شاهدتم التغييرات الكبيره
التي حصلت في المملكه ولكن نحن دائما
مفتتحون لخوض الحوار مع اصدقائنا ولكننا
نستجيب للضغوط عندما نقوم باي شيء نحن
نقوم بذلك حسب مصالحنا ولا اعتقد
بان اي شخص يؤمن بان الضغط مفيد
وبالتالي فهذا ليس بالشيء
الذي حتى سنه تم الاولويه هي تحقيق
الاهداف التي وضعناها لبلادنا نحن نركز
بشكل كبير على بناء المسارات تجاهك
الازدهار المستدام بالشعب السعودي وانا
احسكم انتم وكل لديه اي فضول
لقضاء بعض الوقت في المملكه والتفاعل مع
الشعب السعودي واحكموا بانفسكم
فيما يخص التطبيع اولا وكما تعرفون نحن
ندعم بالكامل اندماج اسرائيلي في الشرق
الاوسط
منذ اليوم الاول
ونحن نعمل من اجل تعذيب بعض العلاقات
القائمه اصلا وكذلك لتوسيعها مع دول اخرى
وهذا يشمل المملكه العربيه السعوديه اعتقد
ان هذه السكون خطوه هامه جدا للمستقبل بلا
شك ستكون اولويه وهي بالفعل اولويه
بالنسبه لنا الاندماج جيد للمنطقه باكملها
وسوف نستمر لتحقيق ذلك ناقشنا ذلك هنا
وسوف نستمر
بالعمل عليها وتحقيقها في الايام
والاسابيع والاشهر المقبله اما فيما يخص
المواطنين الامريكيين وحقوق الانسان بشكل
عام اسمحوا لي انا اقول اولا
حقوق الانسان دائما على جده الولايات
المتحده
ترى ان سعودين خلال الماضيه كما اوضحنا
بان التقدم في حقوق الانسان يقوي علاقتنا
وسوف ان استمر بالتحدث عن ذلك بشكل عام
وخاصه عن حقوق الانسان
هنالك شيء اخر في غايه الاهميه وقد ذكره
مع الوزير الخارجيه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه انطلقت في جهود
جباره وتاريخيه لتحديث
اقتصادها
ومجتمعها
وجزء من ذلك
سيجذب افضل المواهب بك انحاء العالم الى
السعوديه لزيارتها والسعي الى تعلمي هنا
والاستثمار
والمشاركه والعمل الى جانب السعوديين
ومن وجهه نظرنا رؤيه 2030 كما سمى هذه
المبادره
ستحقق نجاحا اكبر بكثير
اذا ما كانت السعوديه اكثر مكانا جذابا
لكف سكان العالم المجيئي اليها وبالتالي
اعتقدوا بان حسب وصفها ومن مصلحه العربيه
السعوديه تستمر
بالسعي لهذه هذا التحديث وتوسيع الحقوق
الانسان اما فيما يخص المواطنين
الامريكيين كما تعرفون كما ذكرت مرارا ان
رفعها وان المواطن الامريكي في كل مكان
حول العالم هو اولويتي القصوى ومسؤوليه
وهذا هو التركيز وزاره الخارجيه ايضا نحن
مستمرون
بالعمل نيابه عن الافراد قدر الامكان
وتسنت لي الفرصه
لطرح بعض المسائل ولن اخوض في المزيد من
التفاصيل
السلام عليكم محمد المحمود من قناه سكاي
نيوز عربيه سؤالي الاول موجه لسمو الامير
في الملف السوداني بعد الجهود السعوديه
الامريكيه المشتركه
والحث على عقد هذه الاتفاقيات التي تمت في
جده ما القادم من الجهود الدبلوماسيه
خصوصا مع استمرار الاشتباكات داخل الاراضي
السودانيه السؤال الاخر لمعالي الوزير
بلنكن قلتم في كلمتكم صباح هذا اليوم
باننا لا نريد ان تصبح افغانستان ملادا
امنا للارهابيين كيف يمكن ان نوفق بين هذا
الكلام وبين الانسحاب الامريكي من
افغانستان الذي فتح المجال امام التنظيمات
الارهابيه والاعمال الارهابيه اخرها صباح
هذا اليوم تفجير في مسجد في افغانستان نتج
عنه 18 وفاه و33 اصابه شكرا لكم شكرا
بالنسبه للسودان اولا اودا نعبر عن خالص
شكري للتعامل الكبير الذي حظينا به من
الجانب الامريكي في المحادثات التي حصلت
في جده للمحاوله
للتعامل مع الوضع الانساني والحرج نتيجه
لما حصل من اقتتال داخل السودان
حققنا بعض النجاح لم يكن نجاحا كاملا لان
الاطراف لم يلتزموا التزاما كاملا ونستمر
في العمل لبحث السبل لرفع المعاناه عن
الشعب السوداني عن طريق الوصول الى
تفاهمات معينه مع الاطراف هناك بوادر
ايجابيه حتى اليوم في المحادثات قد نصل
الى هدنه اخرى مع اليات مراقبه اكثر تشددا
تساعدنا في تحديد مواطن
الخلل او المخالفه ان حصل ذلك وان التزم
الاطراف سيكون ذلك بصيص عمل جديد لاخواننا
في السودان وهنا اوجه كلامي مره اخرى الى
الاشقاء في السودان كافه ان الدم السوداني
غالي وان لابد ان نعمل جميعا على
معالجه هذه الازمه بالحوار وعيدا عن
السلاح لان السلاح لا يحل شيء ولن يفضي
الى سواء مزيد من الدمار ومزيد من
الابرياء يسقطون
فنتجه الى الحوار نتجه الى معالجه الامور
من خلاله ونمتنع عن تعريض المدنيين الى
الخطر باستمرار هذا القتال بذات انه
القتال في المناطق المدنيه وانا واثق ان
الاخوه في السودان
سيتحملون مسؤولياتهم وسيقومون بما يجب
لتجريب المواطن السوداني مزيد من الدمار
والخراب هو مره اخرى سنعمل مع اصدقائنا في
امريكا وكافه شركائنا في المنطقه
واخرون للدفع في هذا الاتجاه
لاطول حرب من اننا سنستمر بالتركيز
على مصالحنا للامن القومي لمن عمليات
الارهاب الناجمه عن افغانستان ضرورين سوف
نتصرف ونعمل على التعامل معها وقد اظهرنا
ذلك بشكل جليل في الشرقيه الماضيه قدرتنا
على فعل ذلك من ضمنها التخلص من احد كبار
قياداتي القاعده الذي يسكن في افغانستان
او يقوم في افغانستان نحن نعمل مشاركه
ودول الجوار لتعزيز القدرات للتعامل مع اي
عمله ارهابيه قد يكون مقرها في افغانستان
او تنجم من هناك وفي نفس الوقت
الطالب عنه
عدو لدعى خراسان
ويعمل ضد هذه الجماعه وبغض النظر عن ذلك
فقد اوضحنا
واظهرنا قدراتنا المستمره للقيام باعمال
تحمي امننا ضد اي ارهاب قد ينجم من
افغانستان
مع الوزاره الخارجيه
اقتصاد في العالم
وهي اكبر الشركه تجاري بشكل طبيعي هنا
الكثير من التفاعلات والتعامل مع الصين
لانها شريكها من المملكه
ولاغلب الدوليه المنطقه واعتقد ان هذه
الشراكه
وفرت لنا فائده كثيره وهذا التعاون على
اكثر سينمو بسبب باثر الصله الاقتصادي على
المنطقه لانه سينمو ايضا مع زياده الصين
ولكن الاعزاء لدينا شراكه انديه قويه مع
امريكا وهذه الشراكه الامنيه
نعيد تجديدها وانعاشات كل يوم تقريبا
ولدينا تمارين عسكريه مستمره ولدينا
التعاون مشاركه معلومات الاستخباراتيه كما
نرى في الجهود في السودان
في اليمن هذه الشراكه مع ملكه تبقى قويه
خاصه في تلك المجالات والمناطق فانا
الا اقول بانها هي لعبه صافي صافري بل نحن
قادرون تكوين شراكات وتفاعلات متعدده
وامريكا تفعل نفس الشيء في حالات عديده
فانا لا امن بهذه النظره السلبيه فنحن
نستطيع نبي شراكه تتجاوز هذه الحدود وقد
سمعت بيانات من امريكا حول الرغبه لايجاد
السبل لتعاونه افضل حتى مع الصين ذلك لا
نشجع ذلك لاننا نرى ان
التعقل المستقبل وهذا يعني التعامل بين
الجميع فيما يخص سوريا من المهم جدا ان
ندرك السياق السياق
حواء ان الوضع الراهن لم يكن ناجحا وكان
عبء المتزايد على دول المنطقه وعلى الشعب
السوري بغض النظر عما عن وجهه نظرنا
تجاهها بشار الاسد ان المسار الوحيده لحل
التحديات الانسانيه التي نواجهها في
الازمه السوريه هي لايجاد المسار لمعالجه
مشاكل اساسيه
والمخافه الاخرى
سنوات وفقط زادت الصعوبه الاوضاع مثلا
لبنان الذي يعيشه اوضاع اقتصاديه صعبه جدا
فليس بسحيم حول هذا اللعب مليونير سوري لا
استطيع تحمل هذه اللعبه طويلا يجب ان
نتجنب الوضع الذي يضعهم في خطر
بان هذا المسار قد ينجم ويمكن ان ينجم على
التاج
بينما فشلت الجهود الاخرى نحن نعمل مع
امريكا واخرون
كلها ضمن اعمل المجتمع الدولي
التماشيا مع قرار المجلس الامن الذي له
الصلاه بالامر
فيما يخص الصين
بمطابق تماما اللي جواب معالي الوزير
الخارجيه اولا نتفقنا في المنطقه
وشراكاتنا وعملنا هنا لا يدور
علاقه باي دوله اخرى بل له علاقه بهذه
الشركات والمصالح للقدم خلال العمل معا
ونستطيع حتى في تحديدا نقدمها للشعب
العالم وقد وصفت بعضها مسبقا وفي نفس
الوقت بشكل خاصه فيما يخص الصين
لقد اوضحنا اننا لا نطلب لاي طرف ان يختار
بين الولايات المتحده او الصين فقط نحاول
ان نظهر
فوائد شراكتنا
والاجندن
الحاسمه التي نقدمها وما نحاول فعله
وكل ما سمعته على مدى العاملين ونسخ
الماضيين وحتى الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
من الشركاء حول المنطقه والعديد منهم
كانوا حاضرين هنا في رياض الولايات
المتحده تبقى
الشركه المفضله لاغلب دول المنطقه
فيما يخص سوريا
مره اخرى ليس سرا نحن لم نعتقد
بان اعاده اندماج سوريا الجامعه الدول
العربيه كانت صحيحه ولكن في نفس الوقت نحن
نرى بين اهدافنا متشابهه فيما نحاول
تحقيقه موقفنا واضح جدا
لن نطبع العلاقات مع الاسد ومع هذا النظام
لانه لم يستحق هذه الخطوه تجاه الاعتراف
بها او القبول به
ولكن
لان الاهداف متطابقه تقريبا فاعتقد بان من
اجل مضي قدم وكما وصف مع الوزير الخارجيه
فربما سنحقق بعض التقدم وكلنا نرى
بالتواصل الى حل في سوريا
يتطابق مع قرارات مجلس الامن 22 54 نوسع
امكانيه الوصول لمساعدات الانسانيه الى
الشعب السوري ونضمن عدم
بروزي 11 مره اخرى ونريد الظروف الامنه
لعوده اللاجئين
ومكافحه تهريب مخدرات
كبيره في المنطقه وتقليل نفوذ الايراني
فما سمعنا وما سمعتموه مره اخرى من وزير
الخارجيه هو نيه شركه عينه لاستغلال
يتفاعل مباشر مع نظام الاسد من اجل تحقيق
المزيد من التقدم في هذه المجالات ومجالات
اخرى خلال الاشهر القادمه
على ان اعتمد باننا متشككون من رغبه الاسد
في اتخاذ الخطوات اللازمه ولكننا متوائمون
مع شركائنا هنا حول ما هي تلك الخطوات
وحول الاهداف النهائيه
شكرا جزيلا
وقال المؤتمر الصحفي نشكركم اصحاب السمو
المعاني شكرا لكم
كانت هذه وقائع المؤتمره الصحفي لوزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
ونظيره الامريكان بعد الاجتماع الوزاري
الذي انعقد في الرياض اعزائي المشاهدين
للتحالف الدولي لمكافحه داعش ابرز ما قاله
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه ان تهديد تنظيم
داعش لا يقتصر فقط على دول الساحل بل
العالم كله ونؤكد على ما كانت العلاقات
السعوديه الامريكيه ومن المؤسف ان دولا
متقدمه ترفض استعاده مواطنيها من مخيم
الهول اكثر من موقف اطلقه وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه على ابرزها في ملخص موضوع
التطبيع
ردا على سؤال قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
ان التطبيع يصب في مصلحه المنطقه لكن يجب
معالجه القضيه الفلسطينيه ايضا ودون وجود
سلام مع الفلسطينيين فان اي تطبيق مع
اسرائيل ستكون فائدته محدوده في مخص
الازمه السوريه قال ان حل الازمه في سوريا
يتطلب الحوار مع دمشق لكن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي رد بالقول ان لم تطبع العلاقات
مع النظام في سوريا على كل لمزيد من
المتابعه حول
موضوع هذا الاجتماع وهو التحالف الدولي ضد
داعش ينضم الي من بغداد لمزيد من
المتابعات فاضل ابو رغيف هو الباحث في
الشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه الاعلى وسهلا بك
مجرد ان ينعقد هذا المؤتمر في الرياض
زمانا ومكانا هل هذا يعني ان داعش ما زال
يشكل خطرا محدقا على دول المنطقه والعالم
ام لا يعني هذا الكلام غير صحيح داعش مني
بهزيمه النكره ولن تقوم له قائمه ابدا
تحيه طيبه لك ولمشاهدي قناتك الكريمه يعني
اولا داعش تنظيم ايدولوجي وتنظيم عقائدي
نعم داعش يمرض لكنه لا يموت ياكل لكنه لن
تنقطع بعض ارتداداته لكن هذه الارتدادات
حقيقه حينما تكون ببعض العمليات البسيطه
ضمن مفارز مقتضبه جدا يتم مكافحتها بصوره
عاجله وسريعه حقيقه هذا المؤتمر جاء لينهي
ما تبقى من بقايا هذا التنظيم خصوصا في
بعض في بعض الدول مناطق افريقيا وبعض
مناطق اوروبا الشرقيه وفي سوريا وكذلك في
العراق دعني اقول لك ان انه يتواجد ضمن
نطاق ضيق جدا باعتبار بعد انكسار شوكتها
وانطفاء جدوته فيما يسمى بدوله التمكين ما
عاد لهذا التنظيم قدره المبادئه والمبادره
في تنفيذ عمليات وغزوات كما كان ينفذها
ابان عام 2014 هو ما قبلها وما تلاها
بقليل لذلك اعتقد هذا المؤتمر مؤتمر نافع
جدا ومهم جدا لمعالجه جمله امور حقيقه لفت
انتباه
سؤال السؤال المطروح سؤال المركزي هل
تسرعت بعض الدول الكبرى في العام 2020
بالاعلان عن هزيمه تنظيم
داعش والان تعيد النظر مجددا في سياساتها
بعد ان ثبت ان داعش مازال يملك هامشا
كبيرا من المناوره
يعني اولا التنظيم انتهى يعني انتهى
عسكريا تعبويا ميدانيا تواجديا تمكينيا
دعني اقول لك المعركه الان هي ليست معركه
معركه بريه ليست معركه قتال انما الان هي
معركه معركه استخباريه امنيه معلوماتيه
تتداولها الدول ضمن تبادل المعلومات لذلك
اليوم الجاره الشقيقه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هي والعراق حينما يتم الاتفاق
سويه على تبادل المعلومات تبادل
الداتا استبادل الهيكليه بين بين العراق
باعتبارنا العراق خزان يمتلك اكبر خزان
معلوماتي للدات بيس في العالم يعني اقطع
لك جازما عن تنظيم داعش والقاعده واكثر
يعني التنظيمات الرديكاليه المتطرفه التي
غزت العراق ما بعد 2003 لذلك اعتقد هذا
التعاون سيثمر عنه الانهاء وانجاز ما تبقى
من بقايا التنظيم خصوصا اذا علمنا انه
اليوم اهتمام هذا المؤتمر
يعني معالي وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير
فيصل حقيقه يعني كان كان له يعني اشاره
جدا جيده وهي انه حث الدول على ضروره
استقبال جميع يعني معتقليها او موقوفيه
مما التحقوا بالتنظيم الذين يتواجدون في
مخيم الهول مخيم الهول القنبله الاكثر
موقوتيه على العالم طيب ساكتفي بهذا القدر
من بغداد فاضل ابو رغيف الباحث في الشؤون
الامنيه والسياسيه شكرا جزيلا لك
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
اشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع في محيط
مجمع الصناعات العسكريه في الخرطوم
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه كشف اربعه مسؤولين اوكرانيين
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه يعملون في
القوات المسلحه كشفوا ان الهجوم المضاد
الذي طال انتظاره قد بدا لاستعاده سياده
دوله اوكرانيا ووفق المسؤولين الاربعه فان
القوات الاوكرانيه كثفت هجماتها على طول
خط المواجهه في جنوب شرق البلاد وذلك بهدف
تحرير مدينتي
سيطرت عليهما روسيا ضمن عملياتها العسكريه
الخاصه
قائد مجموعه العسكريه الروسيه قال من جهته
ان المعارك على الجبهه تؤكد ان اوكرانيا
بدات هجومها المضاد واوضح بريكوجين في
تصريحات صحفيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه تكثف
من هجومها على جبهات القتال كما تم
التخطيط له واعرب قائد فاجنر عن امله في
ان تتمكن القوات الروسيه من التعاون مع
هذا الهجوم وصده مؤكدا ثقته في الجيش
الروسي
وفي تطورات انهيار سته كخوفكا قال النائب
الاول لوزير السياسه الزراعيه والغذاء
الاوكراني قال ان خسائر المحاصيل في
الاراضي الخاضعه لسيطره اوكرانيا في
مقاطعه خرسون بسبب انهيار سد محطه كخوفك
للطاقه الكهرومائيه بلغت اكثر من مئه الف
طن مضيفا ان اجماليه خساره اوكرانيا من
المحاصيل قد تبلغ عشرات الملايين من
الاطنان المتحدث باسم الكريم
اكد من جهته ان تفجير خط انابيب الامونيا
يعقد الموقف فيما يتعلق بتمديد صفقه
الحبوب وقال ان مثل هذا الحادث يمكن ان
يؤثر بشكل سلبي على مصير صفقه الحبوب
معك
من مدينه
العربيه رائد الاغبر رائد اهلا وسهلا بك
هل فعلا بدا الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد هل
يمكن لمس ذلك كما تتحدث وسائل الاعلام
ومسؤولين اخرى اوكرانيين وهل نحن نتحدثون
عن هجوم شامل كبير مضاد ام لا مجرد عمليات
استنزاف للجيش الروسي
يعني طالب بالفعل هنا يعني المنطقه
بمجملها زباروجي وخرسون يعني تتعرض
لهجومات يوميه من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
هجومات مضاده والدفاعات الروسيه هناك
الخنادق الطويله الممتده على طول الطريق
لكن نحن الان دعني يعني الصوره تظهر لنا
المكان الذي نتواجد فيه طالب هذه الصوره
هي من نهر ديني ابره ونحن الان في نوفاكا
خوفكا مكان
انهيار السد وتدمير السد وهذا هو نهر
دنيبرو ونرى التيار وسرعه التيار اثراء
الفيضانات التي تمتد على طول هذا النهر
هنا امامنا هذه الكاتيدرائيه التي تقريبا
غرقت بكاملها والمحيط هنا حولنا المكان
الذي نقف فيه طالب كان قد غارقا يوم امس
نوجه
على بعض المسائل
هنا طالب هذه اشارات لبعض
المناطق التي كانت مليئه بالالغام في هذه
ميخادين المليئه بالالغام الطالب
ايضا من الناحيه الاخرى هنا هذه
بعض الخنادق التي
كان يتمركز فيها الجيش الروسي وانسحبوا
بعد لو تضع الفم التي تخندق فيها الجيش
الروسي
اسف اسف هذه الخنادق التي كان يتمركز فيها
الجيش الروسي وانسحب اثر الفيضانات التي
وصلت الى مناطق مختلفه
الحديث عن ارتفاعات هائله وصلت اليها في
هذه المنطقه طبعا هذا هو كلوب ياخت الحديث
عن نادي اليخوت الذي غرق بالكامل في هذه
المنطقه طبعا هذه المنطقه هنا باكملها
جورج هذه المنطقه منطقه عسكريه
والسكنات العسكريه والخنادق التي ملات
المكان كلها فارغه خاويه انسحبت جيش
الروسي من هذه المناطق واثار القصف الذي
كان قبل ذلك وايضا اثار الفيضانات في هذه
المنطقه ربما الكاميرا تسلط الضوء طالب
واضح من حجم الدمار الذي في المنطقه بان
الصوره ابلغ من الحديث ايضا ننظر الى هذه
السكنات في هذه الناحيه المتارس التي كان
يتحصن بها
هناك استعدادات خلف هذه المنطقه للجيش
الروسي بخنادق حديثه شيدت خلال الاشهر
الماضيه لان الجيش الروسي هو يشيد منذ
فتره ويقول ويؤكد بان
حراكه هو دفاعي في الفتره الاخيره
لمعرفته بحجم الاسلحه التي يقدمها الغرب
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه الجهود وعلى هذه
الجهود وعلى هذه الصور التي تردنا من
تحديدا المناطق التي غمرتها الفيضانات
نتيجه قصف هذا السد سنكون معك في نشرات
لاحقه لموفاتنا باي جديد رائد الاخبار من
ميليتو
شهد محيط مجمع الصناعات العسكريه في جنوب
الخرطوم شهد الشبكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع بعد اعلان الاخيره
السيطره عليه وقال شهود عيان انهم سمعوا
اصوات اطلاق نار واشتباكات كما شاهدوا
حريقا في المنطقه المحيطه بمجمع اليرموك
ويعتبر هذا المجمع من ابرز منشات التصنيع
العسكري في السودان وتاتي هذه الاشتباكات
غداه اعلان قوات الدعم السيطره الكامله
على مجمع اليرموك ومستودعات الذخيره مشيره
الى ان جنود الجيش فرو تاركين خلفهم كميات
من العتاد العسكري والمركبات
مع من القاهره لمزيد من المتابعه لواء ابا
بكر ابراهيم احمد وهو الخبير العسكري
السابق في القوات الجويه السودانيه لواء
بكر اهلا وسهلا بك كيف يجب ان نظر الى هذه
الاشتباكات والمعارك في محيط مجمع
الصناعات العسكريه وهل فعلا تمكنت قوات
الدعم السريع من السيطره على المجمع
نعم التحيه لك وللمشاهدينك مجمع اليرموك
كما تفضلت هو من اكبر المجمعات
التصنيع الحربي وهو مجمع استطاعت القوات
الدعم السريع السيطره عليه ربما تعزز
موقفها التفاوض في
السعوديه خاصه وجود هذه القيمه الامريكيه
السعوديه التي تعقد الان في السعوديه
الاحداث حدثت امس
ويبدو ان القوات الدعم السريعه حاولت بقدر
الامكان ان ترفع من مستوى او وجودها
الحربي على الارض كما قلنا لدعم موقفها
التفاوضي في السعوديه
قوات الدعم السريع جمعت تقريبا كله
عرباتها القتاليه لهذه المهمه واكثر من
خمسين عربيه
وهذا المجمع تحرسه سريه من القوات المسلحه
استطاعت رواه الدعم السريع في اول
الاشتباكات ان ان تحتل المناطق امام
المجمع وعلى مشارف مدخله لكن المجمع مجمع
كبير عده في عده
انسحب
القوات المسلحه
تترك المجال الى قوات الجويه لتعمل مع
القوات التمرد لك ان الموقف الان ان قوات
المسلحه قد سيطرت اعاده السيطره بعد عده
ساعات من دخول قوات الدعم السريع الى
مشارف مدخل اليرموك ساكتفي بهذا القدر من
القاهره ابا بكر ابراهيم احمد الخبير
العسكري شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
قالت الشرطه الفرنسيه ان اللاجئا سوريا
اصاب اربعه اطفال وشخصا بالغا في هجوم
بسكين متنزه في مدينه انسي جنوب شرق فرنسا
مضيفه ان بعض الضحايا هم في حاله حرجه
بالمستشفى وقال مسؤول بالشرطه ان المهاجم
سوري الجنسيه وحاصل على وضع لاجئ في
السويد وقال مصدرهم في التحقيقات انه لم
يكن معروفا لدى الاجهزه الامنيه وان
دوافعه لم تتضح بعد
الرئيس الفرنسي من وين ماكرون وصف عمليه
الطعن بالعمل الجبان وقال ماكرون ان فرنسا
في صدمه بعد هذه الحادثه من جانبه قال
وزير الداخليه جيرالد دارمان نان ان
الشرطه اعتقلت المهاجم وهو في الثلاثينيات
من عمره
معي من باريس مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا
حسين فيا اهلا وسهلا بك اولا جديد او هل
توضحت ملابسات عمليه الطعن هذه والعدد
النهائي للاصابات
خصوصا قيل انه بعض الاصابات خطيره جدا
اهلا بك يا طالب نحن في الواقع غادرنا
باريس او نحن الان على طريق سريع بينها
وبين انسي اصبحنا اقرب الى انسي الجديد
الذي ورد على لسان مدعيه عام المدعيه
العامه عفوا للجمهوريه في انسي التي عقدت
مؤتمرا صحفيا مشتركا مع رئيسه الوزراء
اليزابيث بورن التي وصلت مع وزير الداخليه
جيرال دغمنا الى هذه المدينه التي شهدت
الماساه ماساه الاعتداء على الاطفال قالت
المدعي العامه للجمهوريه انه لا يمكن
الحديث عن هجوم ارهابي ليس هناك عناصر
تسمح بالاعتقاد بان هناك دوافع ارهابيه
ولكن هناك محاوله قتل يجري حاليا استجلاء
غوامضها وكشف الدافع الحقيقي
للمعتدي الضحايا من الاطفال هم اربعه ومن
الكبار هم اثنان هناك طفل الالماني يبلغ
من العمر 22 شهرا فقط اي اقل من عامين
اصيب بجراح خطره طفل بريطاني عمره عامان
ايضا اصيب بجراح خطره وهناك طفلان فرنسيان
هما شقيق عمره عامان واخته عمرها ثلاثه
اعوام وهناك ايضا جريح في الثامنه
والسبعين من عمره اصيب مرتين بطعنات سكين
المعتدي وبرصاص الشرطه لدى محاولتها توقيف
المعتاد وقد نجحت في توقيفه والجريح
السادس اصيب بطعنات السكين ولكن بجراح
متوسطه رئيسه الوزراء قالت ان فرنسا كلها
تحت الصدمه وهو التعبير نفسها التي الذي
استخدمه الرئيس ماكرون وقالت انه هجوم
وحشي على اطفال المهاجم عرف عن نفسه بانه
مسيحي من سوريا عثر بحوزته كما قالت مصادر
الشرطه لوسائل الاعلام على صليب وعلى كتب
صلاه مسيحيه متزوج من سويديه وله طفل عمره
ثلاثه اعوام كان حصل على صفه لاجئ قبل شهر
ونصف وكان حاول عبثا في فرنسا الحصول
العام الماضي من المكتب الفرنسي لللاجئين
على صفه لاجئ لم ينجح في ذلك بل حصل عليها
في السويد ودخل الى فرنسا بصوره قانونيه
طالب سيكتفي بهذا القدر من باريس مدير
مكتب العربيه في فرنسا حسين فيا قنيبر
شكرا جزيلا لك حسين على كل هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
علقت اداره الطيران الفيدراليه الامريكيه
الرحلات الجويه من شمال شرق ولايه اوهايا
الاوهايو المتجهه الى مطار لاغوارديا في
نيويورك بشكل مؤقت وذلك بسبب حرائق غابات
كندا المستعره والتي يؤثر سحابها الكثيف
على مدى الرؤيه مرجحه انها ستحتاج الى
اتخاذ مزيد من الخطوات لمعالجه حركه
المرور في كل من مدينه نيويورك واشنطن
وفيلادلفيا وتشارلوت بولايه نورس كارولينا
معي مينيويورك الصحفي طارق الدمشقي طارق
اولا المشهد من عندك كيف يبدو وابرز
الاجراءات التي اتخذتها السلطات الامريكيه
للحد من تداعيات
انبعاث هذا الدخان خصوصا على مستوى
الرحلات الجويه او على مستوى الاستنشاق
لانه اكثر من 100 مليون امريكي الان
معرضون لهواء ملوث كما يقال
اهلا طالب نعم حقيقه يعني الحركه الجويه
في نيويورك خاصه في ثاني اكبر مطار في
مدينه نيويورك والذي يسمى لاغوارديا علقت
البارحه اظن انها عاده الان ليس هناك
تاكيدات حول ذلك من السلطات ولكن حركه
الطيران الجوي حتى في المطارات القريبه
الاخرى مثل مطار نورك الشهير ايضا هناك
تاخير
ويعني
تخفيضات في حركات الجويه الوضع العام
اليوم كما ارى من مكان هذا افضل بكثير من
البارحه
بنسبه التلوث الهواء حكمت ولايه نيويورك
البارحه قالت ان منطقه بروكلين الشهيره في
مدينه نيويورك يعني وصلت مستوى التلوث
فيها الى درجه يعني لم تسجل في تاريخ
الامريكي ابدا قبل ذلك حسب مؤشر جوده
الهواء
وصلت تقريبا الى 420 درجه وخمسين درجه
تعتبر مقبوله وامنه يعني هناك زياده
تقريبا نعم حوالي 800 في المئه وهذه درجه
كانت جدا خطيره مما دفع عمده المدينه الى
يعني
الانشطه انت وافق متابعتك هل تقول السلطات
الامريكيه الى متى ستبقى الامور على هذا
النحو ام لا يعني تتوقع تحسنا وهل هنالك
اي خطر بامتداد هذه الحرائق الى الاراضي
الامريكيه
حقيقه
الحرائق في مناطق الغابات يعني بدات منذ
ثلاث ايام في مناطق كثيره في ولايه
نيوجيرسي ولايه نيوجيرسي تدعى بيل جاردن
ستيت اي مدينه الولايه المليئه في الغابات
هناك الكثير من الحرائق ولكن لا تشكل يعني
هذا الخطر الكثيف كما يوجد في شرق كندا
هذه العاصفه الدخانيه التي اتت من الشمال
بسبب حركه الرياح يعني اثرت على اكثر من
90 مليون
امريكي يعيش في الشمال الشرقي الامريكي
طيب
انا للاسف للاسف للضيق الوقت يعني شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه الصحفي طارق
الدمشقي من نيويورك
الخامس مستمره فيها ايضا
بركان وكيليوا في هاواي احد انشطه
البراكين على الكوكب يثور مجددا
اهلا بكم مجددا ثار بركان كيلوا في هاواي
احد انشط البراكين على الكوكب مجددا واوضح
علماء هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه ان
ثاني اكسيد الكبريت المنبعث من البركان
سيتفاعل في الغلاف الجوي ويخلق ضبابا
بركانيا وياتي ذلك بعد اشهر ثوران
للبراكين في ماونا لغه وهو احد اكبر
البراكين في العالم الذي نشط في نهايه عام
2022 بعد اكثر من اربعين عاما من السبت
نشره الخامسه انتهت اطيب التحيات والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات